what does a footy pro do when he's
retired Christophe met said I went back
to his roots we caught up with him in
the town of how to nams a where it all
began and where he has returned after a
glittering life at the top in that dump
I buddy I am very grateful for the
career that I was able to have I managed
to play for some fantastic clubs
including real madrid i played in big
tournaments for my country I'm very
proud of my career but I also tried to
round it off properly and in the end I'm
just a kid from hot tunas a who went out
to discover the world with the vitafish
bhavik at all Tottenham's a is to the
north of the footballing mecca that is
the Ruhr Valley not far from Dortmund
and Schalke it's home to some 37,000
people many professional players have
gained coaching experience here such as
vote from vodka and Peeta nuova like met
Zelda Benedict vividus was born here we
went out onto the streets to see what
people had to say about how tins most
famous son yes I know him of course he's
a heightened boy he was born here
there's no llega beauty yeah feasible I
think it's great especially because he's
gone back to his old clumping so respect
was picked close but sure this is met
Zelda city of course really but he
doesn't really stand out here when he's
about to town it says hi to everyone
everyone knows him he belongs here
sneaker got two Russians equal gay I
think it's really good that he's
involved here and that he's giving
something back to his hometown it's
really good lady would often he's an
icon everyone knows met Zelda he's cool
always kept his feet on the ground it's
just a shame he went to chaka
who gets the opener Christoph metzeler
got his first bundesliga experience with
borussia dortmund in two thousand within
two years they had won the Bundesliga he
played 47 times for Germany including
the 2002 world cup final at the 2006
tournament on home turf Mets ella was
part of the dream team that won the
hearts of the nation he moved on to
Spain and won the league with real
madrid then back to Germany and three
years at Schalke winning the German Cup
in 2011 after 13 years at the top Mets
alert retired business thank me l is it
hard to leave the golden cage or
professional football and stand on your
own two feet i canna find welcome to
club yes I thought well there are two
sides to a 15 on the one hand you have
many comforts as a Bundesliga player
because lots of organizational matters
are dealt with for you people book your
travel for you you're looked after all
day and get it out we lack nothing I'm
on the other hand your days and weeks
are planned by other people from the
beginning of June oil preseason starts
to the end of the season in May begin
with Martin in charge of your own
schedule it's mine I your name my hair
was I know you can only do with the club
and the coach tell you to duel finally
so right now my current situation feels
like a great luxury a great freedom busy
in the hoofer because i tend to cram my
schedule but that's my own decision mine
kalina's a bar for Parker I was deceived
on minor I ignore my internal met Zelda
decided to get involved politically and
in 2006 he set up his own charity the
plainly titled Christophe met soda
foundation offers a step up for children
and young people from disadvantaged
backgrounds in the form of better
education prospects the former defender
covers the administration and
organizational costs the foundation
works with schools as well as church and
state run initiatives across Germany
such as the don bosco center in berlin
landia follow mafia stems from my own
experience here in the Ruhr area
especially the seven years endorsement
deal town that was hit hard by all the
industrial changes and where a lot of
these problems just blossom will yet all
child poverty youth unemployment a
generation without prospects with those
were areas i decided to flag up on diba
thigh Thea DVF define extreme up metsä
there is vice president of the Players
Association and wrote a book on the
dangers of child prostitution in 2004
with teammate Sebastian KO we asked him
whether all football stars should be a
socially-conscious somebody moved us
constantly I've always concentrated on
things that I can achieve with the
people around me he will my mitts vac
shelf incontinent believe me that takes
up a lot of time and energy and ideas /
new theme different in a given
definitely did and so I think it's
better to approach these kinds of things
with a positive attitude and again
frustrated and accuse others of doing
too little on Van Thieu clogging the
Seas of Enoch muffin in the middle of
our suit another reporter turns up for
an interview fenced off met seda is a
media personality in germany and since
joining the pay TV channel Sky this
season as an analyst his popularity has
grown further how strong logs woke ya
yes very strong tacklers just as we
expected Dortmund have a high rate of
missed passes they make awkward
opponents for Dortmund fables TV pundit
is not closed off metas only day job
this summer he became managing director
of a sports marketing company it's yet
another ball to juggle for the former
defenders is this how we envisioned his
retirement from the game Yas is from few
yes it is quite a lot I'll admit I don't
know some of my obligations have turned
out to land a lot more of my time than I
expected but anyone who's played for
Borussia Dortmund and Schalke should be
able to cope with it you touch the diff
to business school of the time but Mets
elder could not hang up his boots
completely he started playing with his
local club toast hot on again in the 7th
division a chance to enjoy the game
without all the pressure of the top
flight at twist haughton football is
played the way it used to be before the
game was a big business
will you still get butterflies like you
used to oh my hold items here even more
why my vibes because i'm playing for my
club it's like coming down onto the
pitch from the stands North corridor zoo
tube una of let's get as absurd as it
may sound Mets other clearly enjoys life
in the seventh division the former
Bundesliga star certainly doesn't put on
any airs yeah I someday hopefully he's
very helpful to me it gives us tips and
make suggestions otherwise he's just a
nice guy he's just like you see on TV
someone who gets involved in my new
novel fans in capitola their legitimate
design of fun easy one of us you can see
that is completely unpretentious it's
handy as a cannon I've known him for a
while because I'm from Halton I know
what he achieved in his footballing
career it's a nice surprise to have him
since of the start it wasn't clear
whether he was going to play for us or
not but he is playing and he definitely
helps us especially as a personality on
the pitch the kalphite met Zelda has
long been known as a personality off the
pitch in 2008 he saved his boyhood club
from bankruptcy
he followed up by acquiring sponsors and
helping with publicity it's no
exaggeration to say that toast wouldn't
exist without him that made him a legend
in haughton OMSI a friendly against a
team from nearby a config metse is
playing in midfielder rather than in
defense just for fun he's using his time
at toast Halton prepare for what he
hopes will be the next station of his
footballing career a job as a commercial
manager at a major club in esteem 0
finds management I've always been
fascinated by the idea of managing a
club we've been doing the past year set
toast hot tub is something similar on a
smaller scale ultimately danza pool we
have only a thousand members instead of
50,000 but a lot of things are the same
within the club and the surrounding
environment with one month off then
doctor I've always been interested in
coming up with strategies and shaping
things you started to the shamu gift
card it was there until theatre
given meds elders drive and energy you'd
bet on him to succeed but toes Hutton
has clearly also offered him the
opportunity to come back down to earth
after his stellar career
other former football players have
fallen into deep depressions Mets other
seems like a regular salt of the earth
guy just I've see you back here soon or
as a big-time manager or maybe even a
politician